[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Monday everybody oh you look
fantastic so tonight I want to talk
about a fascinating story right out of
Los Angeles a place where your yard is
someone else's Campground 911 calls are
answered slower than Airline customer
service and the governor looks like a
die-hard villain
but now there's a huge strike going on
that could affect a business that's near
and dear to all of us which means
okay
there's a civil war
Bond
and it's delicious
well wait what'd you think I was talking
about the writers strike
I mean do you people even care
missing Hollywood Riders is right up
there with missing Geraldo Don Lemon and
jock itch
never over
what do I care
so on Friday workers in the Cinnabon in
La declared a strike and filed a civil
rights complaint against their employer
the reason the owner installed a policy
Banning political statements in the
store including Pride Flags
Pride Flags
oh it didn't happen again phew but it's
true and execu oversees a bunch of
Cinnabons sent out a message declaring
that we do not discriminate or celebrate
any particular race ethnic group
gender-specific group religious group if
any store is displaying a pride flag
it's to be taken down immediately and
one of the workers asked if a rainbow
pin would be okay he said quote
non-specific pins are okay but sports
teams groups School pins are not in
other words let's stick to doing what
Cinnabon does best making all of us
grotesquely fat
[Laughter]
now personally I have no problem with
the store that wants to fly rainbow
Flags you can fly a flag for the
Bolivian National pickleball team for
all I care that sport combines two of my
favorite things pickles and balls
but just get my order right that's all I
ask I mean why is it so hard to pour the
McFlurry directly down my pants
oh my God
so why is this a story it's entirely
reasonable to demand employees not turn
your bakery into a political rally and
the owner employs openly gay workers at
the store so clearly he's not
discriminating but that's not the way
the workers took it instead they called
it homophobic one said the policy made
it feel like she had to hide herself
adding quote I started to not feel
comfortable in my own skin it really
lowered my self-esteem and I was
starting not to like myself when I
looked in the mirror
so wait is that from the ban on flags
because it sounds like she just ate a
Cinnabon
[Laughter]
I mean that's exactly how I feel when I
eat a Cinnabon I hate myself
I can see the pastry in the mirror
making its way down to a love handle and
hearing lies a great philosophical truth
brought to you by Cinnabon as a human
being you are two people the present to
you and tomorrow's you and how
tomorrow's Greg feels about himself
depends on what present day Greg eats
so if president Greg ate a Cinnabon
right now I'd feel pretty good but
tomorrow's Greg will hate his guts
so the secret to life is getting your
present self to look after tomorrow's
self first and that's the only identity
you should care about not this other
now oh stop it
I don't like smatterings of Applause I'm
like full Applause
that's so much better now now where did
Americans get the idea that your office
space is supposed to be some some form
of self-actual is actualization you're
there to do a job not to have your
virtues validated as for the owner it
was just doing the right thing he faces
a civil rights complaint
civil rights since when did where you
work become your right to wear whatever
you want when Fox clarified their must
wear pants to the office policy
didn't like it but I but I respected it
and they're striking for their right to
wear a button I mean do you think when
unions were invented it was for that do
you think kids making shoes for Nike
somewhere in a warehouse in China are
like hey you go girl
now the employee also worried that she
could be attacked for who she loves
adding it's a dangerous world out there
and we just want to feel safe
and what world could be more dangerous
than working at a Cinnabon
doctors call that job the Widowmaker
but the upside is if there's ever a
robbery the frosting could be used to
seal gunshot wounds
now I get being worried about safety in
California but to equate not wearing a
pin as life-threatening shows you how
much the left has perverted the idea of
safety everyone wants to feel safe is
always said before they cancel a speech
I hate to tell you you d-bags no one is
that interested in you enough to do you
harm why do you think fake hate crimes
exist people living bored in very safe
lives need to fantasize that they're not
look most people don't care who made
their Cinnabon and they don't want to be
scolded as bigots they want a sugar fix
not a lecture nobody walked into your
restaurant to learn how different and
fascinating you are they don't care who
you slept with last night or if you get
hit by a Mack truck tomorrow
You're simply not that interesting
so schedule your 24-hour celebration of
yourself for later fact is maybe one day
you'll make something of yourself but
wearing a button while you do it
won't help
[Applause]
the closed captioning guy hates her
because she can't keep up most of the
crew crime podcast on Fox Emily campagno
unlike the New York Times the headlines
he writes are intentionally funny editor
of the Babylon B Kyle man
she is like day old pizza ice cold and
found under your bed Fox News
contributor got Tim
and his shoes double as homeless
shelters my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
Emily uh you are a huge fan of the
Cinnabon right yes yes we have them all
the time you actually just go to the
airport for that you don't even have a
flight
that's why I always miss my flights yeah
I'm enjoying my cinema what did you what
do you think about this uh this policy
do you think how is this a civil rights
case it's not you're a lawyer by the way
congratulations thank you for that
um yeah it's not a civil rights issue
that's the whole point so generally
speaking in stark contrast to what these
people are arguing employers can
actually adopt and enforce workplace
rules that prohibit non-work related
activities right and that includes
purely political ones that includes
wearing buttons and shirts and the like
and the fact that these employees are
then you know the quotes that you read
where they're they're going from 0 to 60
that heaven forbid a workplace policy
that's essentially like hey get to work
and
says all buttons are prohibited they're
not saying just the ones that are just
rainbow all buttons right belly buttons
they're they're making they're they're
making a clear stance that all they want
to do is have the workplace be free of
all kinds of political noise and all
kinds of nonsense and the fact that the
employees are extrapolating then I their
self-value their their identities all of
a sudden I can't look in the mirror they
say what if cinnamon doesn't have our
back if I'm attacked in the store I
don't feel safe anymore that's a whole
different issue than them saying please
don't wear a shirt that's going to
distract the customers from that 900
gram fast awesome dessert yeah you need
to have those seeks with their sticks
they are to beat people you know Kyle I
I don't know about you but I will not
have a Cinnabon being frosted by
somebody who isn't gay
well that's a good policy that's my
personal policy that's my personal but I
don't let it infringe on others I'll go
in and I'll ask them if they're gay and
if they say no I will go elsewhere
well it's the number one thing I look
for when I walk into an establishment I
need a special flag that says I am
specifically welcome here yes pile Man
Of The Babylon bee is welcome at this
establishment I don't feel welcome so
yeah yeah I always need the button or
you know some way to tell with their
sexual preferences or I don't feel safe
about eating the Cinnabon they
the idea of what safe is Right remember
what I mean try to like try to like
think about people who went to war and
talking about their safety and now it's
about a pin if I don't by the way it
doesn't make sense
if I can't say who I am I'm in danger
but then people won't know who you are
which means you're safe
the Cinnabon itself is more dangerous
because of its fat content than any of
the policies in the workplace yes these
people are murderers
every every pseudopod kills like 12
people that's a fact
cat have you ever had a Cinnabon
of course not
they are useful though that's how you
know who's the most sad at the airport
yeah yeah
I just thought this was okay look as
somebody who has worked fast food jobs I
will say that I also did not feel that
when I was working at Boston Market that
I was being celebrated as a unique
Dynamic individual right right I was
making minimum wage
that's pretty much the clearest
indication of not being of you you know
celebrating for your uniqueness because
you're making minimum wage it's not
somewhere that you're supposed to be
happy it's not somewhere that you really
can be happy and I know this because I
worked with guys that would come to work
on ecstasy yes
they were still not happy yeah
and if that can't you know change the
way you feel about your job nothing can
that's why I work at an ecstasy making
factory Tyrus when I was growing up good
for you um
I don't know I mean when you have to
bulk up have you ever thought about just
sitting have you ever sat alone with a
case of Cinnabons
it's just like we've all been there yeah
you know it's a Wednesday
she said she'd be home at eight yeah 12.
you called work she's not there yeah and
the operator knows where she is but
doesn't want to get involved yes so you
end up at a Cinnabons just
eating under the way
and just just when you're about to give
up yeah just when you're about to eat
that last
you look at the cinema employee and go
it could be worse yeah yes
this the problem Greg is it's identity
they see their Facebooks and they think
they're influencers and stars you're not
even in a union why has he not fired
them they're at will yeah so as soon as
they took the will to step out and make
signs saying that if I don't get to wear
something and identifies me to be single
out to be special also to your point
Greg if I was a gay Basher or a
homophobe I'd be looking up there's the
rainbow badge attack yes so there's they
don't have that so they makes no sense
you're not singling them out because I
represent Cinnabon I have to wear the
uniform of Cinnabon and it used to be
those weird ass hats too on top of
everything else
no the lemonade place is worse remember
the lemonade Place yellow and the red
and blue yes no I understood that that
was an owner who was letting them know
exactly where you stand yeah
you do what I say you look ridiculous
make your lemonade and your hot dogs and
be about it
you know it was an early called hot dog
on a stick yeah it's like something
horrible yeah everything about but the
point is you're an employee a low-level
employee you should be inspired to want
to get out and above yes I didn't always
get to come to work in summer shorts my
hat on backwards I earned that I'd wear
the same as everybody else and when I
had an opinion the guy at Burger King
was like no it's not your way it's their
way okay if you don't like it quit be
make yourself something of substance
where you can decide I'm gonna wear pins
and flare yes all that other kind of
stuff also they said you couldn't wear
pins for a sports team or a school or
anything so yeah
nothing to take away from the Cinnabon
yeah like if you really want to to just
identify as a Cinnabon
because that's your job yes I'm sweet
and sticky
and don't leave me in a hot car
[Laughter]
and don't smear me on your naked chest
okay that's that's a private message to
Bill hammer
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else